Jess, you were trying to move all
this code around in the last video.
It was really hard for me to follow.
What was up with that?
>> Okay, so with that, I wanted to
create a compact repeatable set of
instructions that could repeat
multiple times, and then take that and
put it into a loop in Java.
>> Wait, a loop?
>> Yeah, yeah.
So remember,
the loop allows you to execute
the same instruction over and
over again, until certain conditions are
met, and then you pop out of the loop.
>> Okay, so the instructions could be,
create a new text field and
then display this string, and
then add this TextView to the ListView.
>> Yes, exactly, so we repeat
that same set of instructions for
every element in the list.
So for example,
we start with index zero, take that
value and display it as a TextView.
And then we do index one, take that
value and display it in the TextView.
And then we move up to index two, take
that value and display as a TextView.
>> Okay, I think we got it.
Okay, so then in the end,
you end up with a list of ten TextViews
that show the numbers one through ten.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Okay.